are talking about this movie which is
part of the
but Professor X you did die in one of
them I was vaporized resurrect but
that's nothing it's only it was only at
the level of DNA that he was vaporized I
mean of course come on yeah yeah I
remember can I just say because I wanted
to say thank you to you all these years
I'm sure I have I hope I have I was very
nervous on that first film I started
three weeks in it was my first movie and
there was a lot going on and there was a
lot of people and I remember you pulling
me aside and saying this at times is
gonna feel uncomfortable it's gonna feel
overwhelming but you're in good hands
and everything's gonna be okay and you
both of you was such heroes of mine I
was a little star-struck but you it was
the first day I met you and you saying
that's of it I never ever forgot it at
the National Theatre in a musical I took
your dressing room straight after you
did you I took a photo yeah
this is a very sausage show
[Music]
you